josefsson herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wir spielen heute kein micro
fielen nicht nur gepresste button
sondern schauen uns einen film an
aber es ist kein regulärer film sondern
ein film der soll man sagen
m steht für sich oder um es anders
auszudrücken es ist der beste film aller
zeiten aber es so lustig und ich wollte
ihnen nicht vorenthalten ich hab den bei
paris nickel gesehen das ist ein youtube
sehr gerne schaut und ich dachte mir
kommen die muss auch selbst mal ein
eigenes video einbauen die quelle ist in
der beschreibung verlinkt bereich das
original anschauen wollt die qualität
ist tatsächlich so beschissen sie haben
es in 63 p hochgeladen es gibt keine
höhere qualität ich würde sagen wir
starten erst mal rein
in diesem film wenn ihr gerade was essen
wollt was trinkt dann lasst vielleicht
lieber seht ihr da unten ansehen
die explosionen achtet man darauf wie da
unten einfach seine hand immer noch ist
und jetzt wie einfach die kamera läuft
die leute verschwinden am rechten rand
am rechten bildrand drauf die
verschwinden
das ist aber dass gerade im quartal 1
von 4 es gibt vier teil davon
jetzt schaut mal auf dieses bild auch
mal darauf wie man einfach so genau sie
ich meine die haben einfach ein bild vom
meer genommen hat also ein bild genommen
und dann noch ein gift von einem
fahrenden schiff darübergelegt wortwitz
und dann noch ein geht von dem hai
das sieht ja diesen schwarzen rändern
das ist so schlecht gemacht
das ist als ob
man das kann man doch nicht machen
drei tage später soll er ihn getreten
haben ein verdammt ich hatte irgendwie
runter aber die berichte hier vom vor
dem wc frische hinten wenn sie getroffen
werden
man schaut euch das an das ist so
unfassbar heiß sogar einen seiten
abgeschnitten
nein nein nein nein das tut einfach nur
weh wie sie die kampfszenen einfach
macht an dem sie denn den hai drehen mit
der bild war die software diese heime in
die augen alte stromnetz
möchte ich kurz erbitten darauf zu
achten dass jetzt einfach mitten im
urwald ein hai auftaucht der heirat
beine
der hai läuft und auf einmal brennt
erwartet man sieht etwas so genau die
kästchen von den green screens jetzt vor
allem den hifi und der fliegt zur seite
weg die fahrt mich jetzt bestimmt was zu
erlaube ich gerade gesehen
ich freue mich auch wasser aufgenommen
ich weiß es nicht